8 30 a.m and the moment panic struck on
a new york city subway train
confusion turning to sheer nightmare as
it became clear shots were being fired
in the middle of a morning commute
at the next station terrified passengers
poured out of the carriages some
obviously struggling with wounds i was
on 36th street i'm going to school
and every the train conductor told
everyone to get on the train
and i didn't know what happened it was a
scary moment and then
at 25th street we're all told to get off
those people screaming for medical
assistance
it was just a scary moment
amid the stampede it appears the suspect
managed to escape late tuesday police
released this picture of 62-year-old
frank james police say he's a person of
interest and are asking for the public's
help trying to find him a rented van in
his name was found abandoned near the
crime scene
we are endeavoring to locate him to
determine his connection to the subway
shooting if any
the two crime scenes the subway and the
van
are very active and are still being
processed
we are asking for anyone's help with
information
cell phone video
witness information
these pictures posted to twitter show
the carnage he left behind
the attack happened at the 36th street
station in brooklyn sunset park leaving
neighbors in shock it was like nine or
so
and you know
we saw commotion we saw
cop cars pulling up so we were concerned
we're going to go outside and check what
was going on
at an evening press conference police
said the shooter fired 33 times a 9
millimeter semi-automatic handgun was
found at the scene the search for the
shooter has expanded to include the fbi
at this time we still do not know the
suspect's motivation
clearly this individual boarded the
train and was intent on violence
we are conducting a highly coordinated
investigation that includes nypd
detectives
the fbi nypd joint terrorism task force
and the atf who have been instrumental
in tracing the firearm and ballistics
the suspect
is a dark-skinned male and was wearing a
neon orange vest and a gray-colored
sweatshirt
we do have a person of interest in this
investigation
but we need the public assistance with
additional information the attack comes
as many new yorkers are increasingly
concerned about rising crime in the
subway system eric adams city's new
mayor has only been on the job for a
little over three months he's a former
nypd police officer himself and he's
made fighting violent crime on the
subway system one of his key initiatives
new york governor kathy hokel said crime
needs to stop we say no more
no more mass shootings
no more disrupting lives no worry
creating heartbreak for people just
trying to live their lives as normal new
yorkers it has to end it ends now
some of the injured were taken to a
local hospital none of their injuries
appear to be life-threatening
a small silver lining on a day likely to
shatter faith and the safety of the
subway for some time to come gabriel
lozando al jazeera brooklyn new york